bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa dj ed oggi
siamo su the cut cut minchia che
pronuncia sexy praticamente ragazzi in
italiano significherebbe il gatto che
aveva al latte fa il nome bellissimo
sarebbe praticamente un range game
quindi un gioco di quelli che mi
piacciono tantissimo e non vedevo l'ora
di iniziarlo e me l'avete consigliate
siccome c'è un gatto come protagonista
ok basta che mi avete consigliato questo
gioco perché deduco che sia bellissima
da giocare c'è un'emozione unica visto
che ci sono i gatti già partiamo da dio
anche perché io adoro questo tipo di
animali voi lo sapete allora iniziamo
ragazzi [ __ ] non anche ma ho
mancato il tasto quindi quando marco il
tasto all'inizio si preannuncia un
grandissimo gioco controlli su e giù se
devo prendere soltanto su e giù in poche
parole come cazzo funziona cos'è sta
roba ragazzo è ragazzi vi sto fumando
qualcosa ove lo vedo andò vedete anche
voi perché è uscito un gatto
io mi muovo il nuovo su e giù così
bellissima perché perché è uscito un
gatto da quel coso ragazzi ma qualcuno
ha fumato qualcosa qui perché c'è sta
roba stranissimo dovevo andare nel
cerchio ora è mica stavo fermo avevo
vinto anche prima son riuscito ragazzi a
morire tre volte in un livello dove
dovevo stare fermo in poche parole
fantastico devo muovermi su e giù e
basta ok ho capito allora fermi un
attimo
porca [ __ ] ma il suo adesso a destra
madonna il pazzo destra
porca ma lo sai cosa vuol dire su una
ragazza non è così difficile mi sembra
abbastanza semplice per ora però non sto
riuscendo lo stesso e questo è
preoccupante è una casa allora
[ __ ] sì sì ora devo andare lì
dentro si ok ragazzi ho capito e si
gioca ci voleva un attimo perché non
sono incapace sono 4 su 18 tra l'altro
qui c'è scritta sono diciotto in totale
in poche parole variation sono morto già
mente un volte fantastico e mi sembrano
tanto difficile fino ad ora sono io che
sono impedito non dovrebbero essere così
difficili per credo ok
piano piano piano piano veloce mai così
vai così
guardalo ok questo non riuscirò mai più
a rifarli in vita mia ma va benissimo è
la madonna ragazzi si sta sta diventando
complicata la faccenda qui ma io ce la
farò lo stesso perché io non temo
nessuno
non temo un cazzo di nessuno e strega
guardalo guardalo lì si no
qualche [ __ ] o quasi fatta rega non
ci posso fermata ragazzi che cosa
c'entrano i gatti sto gioco che c'è un
proiettile che non penso se quello
dovrebbe essere un gatto cioè io per ma
perché hai fatto sempre liliana santi
allora io non ho voglia di rifarmi
livelli anni e anni per andare sono
molto già 50 volte in dieci minuti non è
possibile ma allora cani giuro che una
cosa impossibile allora vai su test
sì sì ok fin qua ci sia un po per il suo
a destra a destra su ok
no no e allora sei stronzo mi mancavano
irrigidendo ragazze e ragazzi non è però
ancora ma sia quello di sotto c'è
qualcosa non sbatto contro il mornico lo
sapevo ragazzi devo arrivare al cerchio
non è possibile allora vai giù a testa
minchia ragazze mi sembra di essere
imbottigliato nel traffico non è
possibile
tua sorella immersa nel latte e anche
colorato sto cazzo di livello quindi
sembra facile ma non è un cazzo facile
ce ne sono ancora 200 di livelli come
cazzo faccio a farli che sono bloccato
al sesto non è normale si son passato ok
ciao ragazzi ce la faccio ce la faccio
non ce la faccio quello che decido io di
cercare stand merde perché mi
consigliate vuoi e io ancora dopo un
anno non ho capito un cazzo di quello
che devo giocare perché dovrei capirlo
quando mi consigliate stand merde per
farmi incazzare mano ancora non ho
capito spero ogni volta che si gioca
gioca strahm cos'è cos'è sta roba non
sarà ok questo l'ho vinto sono stato
fermo e basta
non so se è normale no ma come cazzo
fatta a mancarlo
ragazzi ho fatto un liberale ma questo è
semplice cioè quello di prima era
infatti non è semplice mi chiama un
cipiglio manco se fosse ragazzi centrare
i pugili questo periodo è difficile ma
che cazzo sta dicendo
fatemi arrivare alla fine mamma mia
mamma ecco mammamia un cazzo ma perché
anche tondo come cazzo faccia questo
passo ci sono passato che come non detto
me lo metto cosa dove cazzo sono qui i
ragazzi mi sono poi ci siamo ci siamo
subito subito sì sì mio dio ho fatto
l'ho fatto non ce la farò mai più ma è
andato di culo in una maniera
incredibile ma va bene così a caso ma
[ __ ] sto facendo una cosa pazzesca
perazzi ha fatto tre livelli senza
neanche guardare giampà e pazzesco sto
facendo
mica mi sta spaventando prima ci ho
messo mezz'ora farne uno adesso 10
secondi a farne tre
come cazzo è possibile vai così vai così
gradini caricarsi grandis molti da shawn
e cazzo vuol dire emotive sepe con la
scritta muoio novero non vogliono
infatti invito non detto e io ho anche
rischiato far questo fantastico dove
cazzo dovrei passare di qua di preciso
l'ex basso di quattro assi sito è la
madonna che casino che già prima era di
e va beh ma sei stronzo
già prima era difficile cazzo ci si
mette pure tu grandissimo domandare di
sopra sicuro sapevo si si io mio salto
dio mio santo
ok ok ok ok un cazzo questo sta
diventando impossibile ragazze che prima
siamo partiti e vabbè però siamo partiti
che era semplice sistema sti cazzi vabbè
regalano capelli si va beh ma non
importa non è possibile che va a fan
culo che cazzo centrano i gatti sto
gioco qualcuno ha voglia di spiegarmelo
i proietti è arrivata diventato rosa si
si pone è tanta roba tanta roba tanta
roba tanto tanto sta minchia
però mi sono salvati in una maniera
incredibile e sono morti in una maniera
da polline ragazzi mi sono mancati sti
race game in una maniera che non avete
idea così 17 ragazzi 17 17 cos'è sto
schifo madonna casinò esto livelli
minchia non ci posso credere
c'è chi come cazzo ho fatto sì sì sì
qualcuno mi sta prendendo per il culo
ciò che sto presentimento nonno ma mi
sembra mi sembra molto fattibile non
azzurro sommesso un secondo a fare il
livello di prima che non so con che
cazzo di criterio l'ho fatto così in
fretta ma questo la vedo imposta dove
non vedo neanche il cerchio dove cazzo
devo andare sì va bene che sto cazzo se
l'ha fatto di cocaina qualcosa leggere
perché non è possibile
o sì o sì o sì un cazzo non ce la fa a
fan culo come mai così vai così si sé
una sega non aveva berica come c'è ma vi
rendete conto di che cazzo di livello
sto facendo ma come come con che
criterio dieci minuti 10 fottuti minuti
e 42 secondi
non chiedetevi come non è possibile
chiedere seesmic anne louise lipu elf
ranocchio dei ben fatto e gatto al latte
dormirà felice ancora per un giorno sono
io sono contentissimo guarda per ragazzi
è stato è stato breve ma intenso come
gameplay mi è piaciuto un case anche se
non ho capito il senso perché il gatto
ce l'ha solo alla fine però non i
ragazzi meno ci facciamo domande e
meglio è in questi casi perché non lo so
con kakà io direi che posso concludere
qui anche perché è stato strano
parecchio strano ragazzi nonostante
fosse breve il gameplay spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto doveva
assolutamente farlo perché l'avete che
ha sentenziato in 13mila e almeno almeno
siete contenti spero comunque ragazzi
dei video è piaciuto il common solito la
sua documento mi piace anche la pagina
di facebook con ogni video tratta nelle
sezioni
si scrive the noi ci rimettiamo in un
prossimo video bello ragazzi